Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute geht's komplett marokkanisch zu hier.
Wir machen Pastilla oder "Pastija"? Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie man es ausspricht
aber ich weiß, wie man's macht und das ist das Wichtige!
Ich habe das das erste Mal Ende 2016 - das werde ich nie vergessen -
auf einer Hochzeit probiert, da war ich mit deiner Mama.
Oh mein Gott, das war sooo
lecker!
Es war so lecker! Und Hamza ist jetzt kein Marokkaner, das denken immer viele
wenn ich marokkanische Rezepte mache, Hamza kommt aus Palästina.
Aber ich war eben auf dieser marokkanischen Hochzeit
(H: Danke! Danke, dass du das klargestellt hast!)
Ja doch, nichts zu danken! Also wir lieben Marokkaner, marokkanische Küche sowieso
und ja, deswegen machen wir das heute und zwar im Mini Format!
Das sind dann Hähnchen Pastilla, die kann man sich super einfrieren, super portionieren, mega!
Ich starte jetzt hier direkt mit der Pfanne und da gebe ich zuallererst Öl rein.
Und dann die Zwiebeln auch schon dazu. Ich hab hier ein bisschen was vorbereitet
aber ihr findet die ganz genauen mengenangaben immer in der Videobeschreibung.
Einfach unter dem Titel diesen Pfeil anklicken und dann habt ihr sie da komplett.
Also Zwiebeln rein, was ich auch schon mit rein gebe ist Koriander und Petersilie.
(H: Hast du eigentlich erzählt was Pastilla ist?)
Ja, hab ich wahrscheinlich vergessen weil heute ist der erste Fastentag und ich bin leicht verwirrt!
(H: Macht nichts!)
Pastilla sind so, also man nimmt -
ich nehme z.B. Filoteig und da ist dann eine Hähnchen-Schicht, eine Nuss-Schicht,
eine mit dem, was wir jetzt machen eben, mit Petersilie und Koriander
und es ist vor allem ein bisschen süß und dennoch herzhaft. Es ist einfach so lecker!
(H: Das ist das geile daran!)
Das ist das geile daran! Es ist SO lecker!
So, Zwiebeln sind drin. Wie gesagt Petersilie und Koriander,
dann kommen auch noch Gewürze dazu aber die zeige ich euch gleich in aller Ruhe.
So, da hab ich auch schon frischen Ingwer mit dazu gegeben,
ihr könntet auch gemahlenen Ingwer nehmen, je nachdem, was ihr da habt.
Und jetzt kommen noch meine trockenen Gewürze dazu, einmal Kurkuma einfach mit rein.
So, Zimt. Zimt spielt eine Rolle hier. Also ich bin jetzt nicht soo der Zimt Fan aber bei Pastilla:
mega! Einmal rein, Salz und Pfeffer und Safran. Safran ist auch typisch dafür.
Und ich mach das so - Moment, kurz den Pfeffer -
ich mach das beim Safran so, dass ich den - weil der hat ja so relativ lange "Stängel" sag ich mal,
einfach so ein bisschen verreiben in der Hand, dann werden sie kürzer.
Dann gebe ich das noch mit dazu.
So, jetzt kommt das Hähnchen mit dazu und wird noch von beiden Seiten schön angebraten
aber nicht lange, denn das wird gleich im Wasser gar gekocht.
So jetzt machen wir die Nuss-Schicht und die ist meine persönliche Lieblingsschicht!
Das ist eben der Teil, der auch ein bisschen süß sein wird aber nicht zu süß!
Ihr dürft euch das jetzt nicht zu süß vorstellen!
Ich habe jetzt hier Puderzucker, die Nüsse habe ich vorab angeröstet.
Das sind Mandeln, die ich benutze.
Ihr könnt auch Cashewkerne nehmen oder Pinienkerne, ganz wie ihr möchtet.
Und die habe ich jetzt im Blender auch noch so ein bisschen feiner gemacht.
Nicht zu fein, die dürfen ruhig noch stückig sein, aber das ist auch alles Geschmackssache.
So einmal die Nüsse zum Puderzucker und was jetzt auch gaaanz wichtig, ist ganz typisch auch:
Orangenblütenwasser. Davon gebe ich jetzt auch noch zwei Esslöffel dazu und dann wird das schön verrührt.
So, die Nussmischung ist ja jetzt fertig und jetzt widme ich mich dem Hähnchen.
Das ist jetzt auch gar, das hat bei mir ungefähr 20min gedauert.
Es kommt immer darauf an, wie dick es bei euch ist,
also wie dick die Fleischstücke sind.
So, einmal den Deckel weg. So, jetzt kommen die Hähnchenstücke raus.
Ihr dürft euch jetzt nicht wundern warum ich hier so kleine Stückchen drin hab.
Wir hatten uns ursprünglich für ein anderes Rezept entschieden
und ich hatte meine Hähnchenbrust schon in kleinere Stücke geschnitten,
ihr könnt's natürlich auch ganz reingeben.
So ihr Lieben, als nächstes machen wir folgendes:
das, was jetzt noch übrig ist im Topf, diese Flüssigkeit mit den ganzen Aromen
das nicht wegschütten, das ist jetzt ganz wichtig!
Da geben wir jetzt Eier rein und rühren das nach und nach unter und lassen das noch mal 10min köcheln
damit die Flüssigkeit verdampft und wir so eine richtig schöne - ja, wie so eine Art Paste haben.
Und das Hähnchen, was ihr rausgenommen habt, lasst es ausdampfen sonst verbrennt ihr euch
und dann einfach auseinander rupfen.
Wenn die Flüssigkeit verdampft, dann sieht das Ganze so aus,
also es ist schon sehr fest und halt sehr lecker
weil die ganzen Gewürze da mit drin sind. Besser als wenn ihr jetzt das Wasser wegschütten würdet,
dann wären die ganzen leckeren Aromen ja auch weg, bzw ein Teil davon.
So und jetzt habe ich hier Filoblätter. Filoteig, das ist der gleiche, den ihr auch für Baklava benutzt.
Und ich habe hier auch schon drei vorbereitet und ich zeige euch jetzt, wie ich den vierten vorbereite.
Immer schön unterm Tuch liegen lassen die Filoblätter weil die trocknen sehr schnell aus.
Ich hab jetzt hier meinen Tortenring, hab jetzt hier den Mini-Tortenring auf ungefähr 11 cm eingestellt.
Ihr könnt auch 10 oder 12 nehmen. Ihr könnt auch 15, also es ist vollkommen egal!
Ich mag es jetzt halt so und in meiner anderen Variante im Video von vor 2 Jahren
habe ich den ja glaube ich 30cm groß gemacht aber heute wollen wir ja die Mini Variante.
So, ich lege jetzt den Filoteig hier rein und dann habe ich mir ein bisschen Butter
in der Mikrowelle geschmolzen. Und weil der Filoteig so dünn ist,
bestreiche ich den dann immer mit ein bisschen Butter
und nehme insgesamt so zwei oder drei Teiglagen.
Ich hab's grad mit zwei versucht, das war ein bisschen dünn. Nehmt am besten drei Teiglagen.
So und jetzt nacheinander schichten. Ich nehm zuerst die Nussmischung,
dann gebe ich die Eiermasse dazu und zum Schluss Hähnchen.
Und danach verschließen wir das ganz einfach,
Auch immer ein bisschen Butter drauf geben, schön andrücken
und dann könnt ihr das auch schon auf euer Backblech geben, das habe ich hier mit Backpapier ausgelegt.
Den Backofen habe ich vorgeheizt auf 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze
und dann müsst ihr einfach gucken. Innen ist ja schon alles gar,
das heißt es müssen nur noch die Filoblätter schön braun werden, das dauert so ungefähr 20-25min.
Und dann können wir auch schon servieren
und ich gebe obendrüber ganz traditionell Puderzucker und Zimt.
So und jetzt habt ihr ja nur noch eins zu tun: das Ganze einmal nachmachen
und dann schreibt ihr mir euer Feedback hier unten in die Kommentare.
Habt ihr Fragen? Habt ihr Wünsche? Liegt euch irgendwas auf dem Herzen?
Immer schön in die Kommentare!
Dann können wir miteinander schreiben und ich freue mich jetzt einfach nur noch auf's Iftar
mit dir, mein Hamza! <3
(H: Man merkt das auch voll, dass du dich freust!)
Ja, also heute ist ja wie gesagt der erste Tag - ich weiß nicht, wann das Video online geht -
aber doch, wir haben schon so langsam echt Hunger.
Und es wird auch langsam dunkel, deswegen müssen wir uns jetzt mal beeilen!
Also euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!